- Hi, everyone Sal Khan here
welcome to the "Homeroom" live stream.
We have a very exciting
guest today Anant Agarwal
the founder and CEO of
edX and sorry, I'm messing
with my video settings probably
at the exact wrong moment
but before I get into that
I will give everyone my
standard announcements.
A reminder that Khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position
to do so, please think
about making a donation
at khanacademy.org/donate.
Also wanna make sure to give
a shout out to a whole series
of organizations that
stepped up when they realized
that the world needed Khan
Academy more than ever
during the pandemic but
also to support the world,
we needed more resources.
Our server costs went up.
We were trying to
accelerate a whole series
of content, so special
thanks to Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly and General Motors
for really stepping up
during the pandemic
and beyond the pandemic
and to all of our supporters,
corporate, philanthropic, all
of the above over the years
to really put us in a position
so that we can support as many
of y'all learners as we can.
And last but not least
I want to remind everyone
that there's a version
of this live stream in
podcast form, wherever
you get your podcasts "Homeroom
with Sal The Podcast".
So check that out wherever
you get your podcasts.
Now, with that, I'm very
excited to introduce
our guest today for many,
many different reasons.
Anant Agarwal is the CEO
and really the founder
of edX, he's a co-member of
the then Council of Luminaries.
He is a winner of the
Yidan prize in education
but maybe what most
people don't realize is
that you were my professor in college.
You are my recitation instructor.
I believe it was in either,
it was either in circuits
or signals and systems.
You might remember better.
- I think it was in a
circuits and electronics.
As they say this was the
one case where I think
the professor has learned a lot more
from a student than the other way around.
- Oh, I know so much about
circuits Professor Agarwal.
- Okay, okay, all right.
I will ask you my first question.
- No, I mean, in all fairness
my degree is computer science
and electrical engineering.
It's much more computer science
and my wife rolls her eyes
because one would assume
with an electrical engineering degree
I would be able to be more
handy around the house
but I explain I'm very theoretical
and I'm afraid of
electrocuting myself or others.
So I go, I turned to professional
but give me some software
and I could definitely
go to town with that.
Before we go into what you do now, I mean
I'm sure you remembered me
when I was your student.
In the sea of bright faces.
You're like that kid.
- Yeah, I had you pegged.
When I saw the face I said,
"This person is gonna be one
of the world's greatest luminaries
in terms of teaching and learning."
I had you pegged,
when you went off into the
financial systems and so on
that was a total surprise.
But what you're doing now,
I had you pegged buddy.
- Well, I will take that for
what for what it's worth.
I'm pretty much sure that
you don't remember me.
And I was just a face in
the crowd but let's go
into what you now do.
So for anyone who's been living
under a rock for the past
10 or so years, what is edX?
- EdX is a learning platform
where we connect some
of the teachers and professors
from the greatest institutions
in the world like MIT
and Harvard, Stanford,
Berkeley, Oxford and others
to learners from all over the world.
So it's a platform where the
learners who want to learn
can come in and learn from
some of the best professors
and teachers around the world.
And also from companies like
Amazon web services, Google,
IBM and others.
We have about 40 million
learners on our platform
where learners come in and
they can learn anything
from the humanities to computer science
to data science, business, arts.
You could even learn how to
use mechanical ventilators.
The course that we launched
with Harvard and (indistinct)
during COVID times about a year ago.
And people can also own credentials.
We have these modular
credentials like micro masters
and micro bachelor's that
people can use to up-skill
in their current job.
Or if you've been
furlough, you can use that
to gain new skills for the future.
So this is who edX is and you can come in
and you can start learning.
You can learn for free on the platform.
- How did all of this come to be?
You were a professor, a very
successful professor at MIT.
You had your tenure,
you're running departments.
You kind of gave that up to do this.
What was the evolution of going
from professor to edX and
making this your life?
- Sal, you had something to do with it.
I would trace it back
to, so for me education
has always been something
near and dear to my heart.
I remember as a physics
student in IT Madras
in my first year, I
was one of two students
out of 300 that failed
the first physics exam
and my heart completely stopped.
And at that time I realized that everybody
around me seemed to understand
calculus based physics.
There was no Khan Academy then remember.
And I was here.
I hadn't learned calculus based physics
and I had no idea what
they were talking about.
And so I said, "Look, hopefully
there'll be one day when
everybody will have equal access
to education and come up to
speed as everybody else."
I really got a chance in the year 2000
when MIT launched
OpenCourseWare, I was one
of the early professors to launch
my circuits course on OpenCourseWare.
And then, Sal I've heard you talk about
how you were inspired by OpenCourseWare
and you launched a Khan Academy.
And I heard about your videos
from my children and others.
And at MIT, a number of
us were thinking about
what should the future look like?
We did OpenCourseWare.
What would the next big thing look like?
And then there's a confluence
of multiple technologies
happened around 2008, 2009
like social networking,
video distribution at scale,
cloud computing, mobile computing,
at that time it was very clear that
we could do learning at scale.
And I launched a program called WebSim
as part of our lab where I said, "If
I could teach people how to
do circuits labs fully online
then maybe this is something
we could do at scale."
And so on the average day,
two to 300 students from all
over the world would come
in and do WebSim which is
I think of it as a MOOC lab.
And this was, I built it out in 2003.
- MOOC being massively open online course.
Before (indistinct) open
online courses existed.
- This was nine years
before they existed, 2003.
You could maybe call it a MOOL,
massive open online labs.
It was circuits labs.
And I figured if I could
do online circuits labs
then maybe I could do other things.
But then I did nothing beyond that.
I just kept running the WebSim
and then inspired by you Sal in 2011,
a number of us at MIT got together.
The leadership at MIT,
Raphael Reif, myself,
leadership Harvard,
Alan Garber and others.
We've been thinking about
how could we take this
to the next level?
And that's how edX was born.
When we said, "Look, rather
than just having course materials
as an open course, where
what if we take complete
courses with certificates
with communities and also with labs
and real hands-on experiences
and make that available to the world.
And that's when we launched
MITx in December of 2011
and turned into edX when we partnered
with Harvard and MIT in
early May and launched edX,
that's how it all came together.
- And what made you decide to
make this your life journey?
As I said, you had a
good gig as a professor,
head of departments.
- You know what, it's
one of those things where
as far as life is concerned,
I'm very much an instrumentalist.
I don't plan very far out.
And I sort of take it one base at a time
to use a baseball analogy.
And so when the opportunity arose
we decided we'd create a MOOC platform.
And they initially called
MITx and then called edX.
I was the head of the computer
science and AI lab at MIT.
And it had a 25 strong research group
with PhD students and postdocs
and undergrads and so on.
And so we incubated what would
become edX in the basement
of CSAIL, the computer
science and AI lab at MIT.
And I was looking to
recruit professors to teach
the first course on edX.
And when I told people, yeah
the course needs to start in two months
and oh, by the way we are building
a completely new platform.
We wanted an open source
platform that uses Python
and Django and the latest technologies
and not the old stuff, cloud-based,
there's nothing, nothing
available at that time.
And so my colleague said,
"You're nuts, can't do it."
And so, by that time we had announced edX.
There was no one ready to teach something.
And so, we announced it
and so I jumped in and said,
"Look, we can launch
with the circuit course."
And people looked to me as if I was crazy.
Why would you launch with a
circuits course as opposed
to something like machine
learning or Python programming?
I said, "Look, that's the best we can do.
I could not get my colleagues
to do this quickly enough.
They felt we were nuts."
And so that's how we launched
with the circuits course.
And I kinda got sucked into it having
to do the first course
myself, with several
of my colleagues like
Jerry Sussman, Jacob White,
Chris Terman and others
who were really jumped in
and pitched in to make it happen.
- It's a great story.
And I do wanna ask
where this is all going,
where do you see the future?
But I'm getting an unusual number
of questions coming in
through the message board.
So I wanna make sure I
get to some of these.
This is just kind of a fun question
from YouTube, Anthonine Apolius.
What's your favorite thing in math?
And maybe I'll expand Anthonine's
question a little bit.
What's your favorite thing
in all of knowledge, in all of learning?
- I'll answer both questions.
My favorite thing in math actually was
when I really one day
I kind of just got it.
I really figured out how to
solve differential equations
which is that we try not to overthink it.
You just kind of do it mechanically
and you apply templates and do it.
And actually I remember
in my circuits course
we use first and second
order differential equations
and solutions of those.
And I actually called
up my student who had
a little gig going in California.
And I called him up and said, "Hey look,
I need, your website doesn't
have a video tutorial
on first order differential equations.
So I need you to create something for me."
And this guy did it.
And his name was Khan Academy.
So in my course on edX, I have a tutorial
from Sal Khan on some of the stuff.
But in terms of, in all of learning
I think the thing,
my dream is one day to really
understand quantum mechanics.
I don't understand it.
I've never really gotten it deeply
I can do the math and do
some of the formulate stuff.
But my dream one day is to
really have the time to sit
down and listen to five minutes lectures
and others and really, really,
truly, (indistinct) it.
I'm not there yet.
- It's interesting, my
quantum mechanics and sorry,
are you getting a little
buzz every time I talk,
every time I start to talk
it sounds like there's a
little, did you hear that?
- No, no I'm okay.
- Oh, good, good, good, good.
No, when you mention quantum mechanics,
that is one of those
things that I also want,
I seek to have a deeper
understanding of it
but I think anyone, the
first time you learn it
and you say, "Wow, all
matter has both particle
and wave-like properties
that the electron is a wave
until you attempt to observe it."
And then it collapses, the wave
function collapses and then
you know its position.
Like it's so counterintuitive
to what we think is our understanding
or our perception of the universe.
And actually I probably had
the most interesting insight
that affects my my understanding
of quantum mechanics
when I was reading this
question and answer.
This is recently, this is
what an Indian guru who died
in the 1980s, his name
is Nisargadatta Maharaj
and he wrote this actually,
he didn't write this book.
This book "I am that" is based
on conversations with him.
And he's apparently, had
reached nirvana or moksha
or had kind of reached enlightenment
and people are always
asking him these questions.
And they keep asking him, well,
what is the cause of this?
And what is the cause of that?
And he says, "You are so
obsessed with causality.
What you call causality is
just repeated correlation."
And I was like, is he right?
Is it just repeated correlation?
And I'm still processing that
but that actually in
some ways opened my mind
to things like quantum mechanics
which seem to defy our standard,
our standard intuitions
whatever the intuition is of
causality and correlation.
But yeah, I think that's really-
- I mean absolutely.
I did have a really,
really deep understanding
of Newtonian mechanics and so on.
And maybe that was part of the problem.
I really deeply got it.
And then when you have to
completely rethink things
and change your frame of
reference, almost became
like one of the Yogi Berra quotes,
"wherever you go there you are".
You said, "Yeah, I understand that."
But when you really think about it deeply,
you said, "No, I don't got that."
No idea what that means.
And the deeper I began thinking
about quantum mechanics
and things like that, the more I realize
that while I could do the math
and do calculations, the speed
of light and the compression
of time and all of that stuff
and space, I could do the math
but I never really, really
internalized and got it.
So my dream one day is
to really, really get it.
- Yeah, completely agree.
And it's, yeah, it's, I mean
I could go on into this but like
how much is based on perception.
Anyway, we could go more into this.
Another fun quote from that
guru was when someone, he's like
you ascribe reality to certain things
and you ascribe imagination or dreamlike
to other things but imagine
if your dreams picked
off where they left off the night before,
then all of a sudden you would
have two realities anyway,
we're going way off topic.
But quantum mechanics
makes me think of that.
- I think it goes much better with a beer
in your hand actually.
- We're not, a lot of kids are
watching Professor Agarwal,
you're a role model.
Be careful what you advocate for.
So more questions and really good ones.
Several from (indistinct) on YouTube.
So one of the questions is,
Dr. Agarwal, India and the third world
was hit hard by COVID.
In one of your talks you had
mentioned that there's a plan
to put the entire medical
education curriculum online.
How is that progressing?
- I did give a talk where
we are talking to a number
of universities where the idea is,
could we put an entire
medical curriculum online?
And then the same applies
to computer science,
data science, business.
And we've been sort of
going at it one at a time.
We made huge inroads into
computer science, data science
and business on edX.
We have over 3000 courses
and we're making great
inroads in these areas.
I would say healthcare is gonna be next
where we do have a fair
number of courses at this time
but the idea would be,
imagine if you could learn
about topics like biochemistry,
biology, epidemiology,
pathology, a lot of
the theoretical aspects
for these subjects
but then you go to college and
you learn and you practice.
And you work with real
calibers and all of that stuff.
And you really, really practice
and look at patients and work
with patients and sick people.
That would be the way to do it.
Sort of blended model of learning
where what you could learn
online, you sort of learn online
and then you do all the
practicum stuff when you come
to a physical medical space.
And so to me
that would be something
that is very exciting
and something that we would be interested
in doing in the future.
But again, we started
with computer science,
data science and business,
where we've really built
out a pretty deep
curricula in those areas.
- Yeah, it seems you and
I have definitely talked
about this in the past
that the potential for I mean, medicine
is a big one considering the shortage
of healthcare workers around the world
but there's so many fields that I think
between the edXs of the world
and the Khan Academies of the world.
I think we're actually just at the
at the very early, early stages.
I have another question
here and this is really,
you're clearly an educator
reaching millions.
So there's that but there's also
you were used to be the
head of the AI lab at MIT.
So you know a thing or two
I'm assuming about that.
From YouTube (indistinct) asks
what are your thoughts about the future
of automation in different
fields of technology?
And then I'll add to the question
and given your views of where automation
and machine learning
and robotics are going,
where do you see education needing to go
or maybe even leveraging
some of those trends?
- Oh my God, there's so much
we could talk about here.
Certainly the computer science
and AI lab at MIT is one
of the centers for AI
machine learning research.
A number of other universities and
and companies are also
where incredible research
is happening in AI and machine learning.
And much as computing
and the internet changed the world
in the late eighties,
machine learning and AI
and automation are completely
transforming industry today.
And in the future.
The downside is that people talk
about roughly 50% of today's
jobs will be transformed
into other jobs that will require new sets
of skills where the whole
planet, half the planet
of people need to be
up-skilling and re-skilling.
And that's one of the areas
that edX focuses in very heavily
that we offer professional
certificates the micro masters
and micro bachelors and other credentials
in these topic areas
where people can come in
and re-skill with short courses
and programs and things like
machine learning and AI.
But certainly the same
transformations of industries where
in the past, I'd just
give you a simple example.
Let's say for example, a translation,
when you speak usually humans
would translate what you said
into some other language
at the UN and so on.
You've seen some of these,
you've probably seen
the movie "Interpreter"
where Nicole Kidman was out
there translating in real time
what people were saying.
Now, imagine today that this technology
is there were even as you speak
a machine could be translating you
into one of any number of languages
and machine learning technology
is key to things like this.
Your second question, Sal.
I think the same thing
huge impact will happen
in the learning field as well
where first of all, let me start by saying
the teacher is always gonna be critical.
I think people need to connect
with people and get inspired
and they're looking for mentors and so on.
And I too had some incredible
mentors in my school
and in college.
I'm hoping we can talk about some of that
but at the same time machine learning
and AI can take over many of the tasks.
So for example, I'll give you one example.
One of the things we worked on
at edX was a (indistinct) framework.
Where imagine based on
the solutions that people
were developing for problems,
imagine that you could create
a hinting framework where
if a student got stuck in a
problem, that Sal can give me
a hint and the computer
gives them a hint based
on all the solutions
they've seen in the past.
And so there are so many
things you could do.
Another example is some
amazing work that Berkeley did
where they did research
using edX learner data
where looking at the
progression of learner activity
they could tell when a
learner was going to drop
out of a course.
And so using machine learning
and then based on that
you could actually create
interventions and mentorships
that happened just at the
right time to enable someone
to get more motivated
and to stay the course.
And these are just two examples.
Georgia Tech has done and
IBM have done research
in some edX courses where
the teaching assistants
in the discussion forums,
the live teaching assistants
have been experimentally
in some cases replaced
by the AI technology where
some of the questions
were answered again, using
machine learning as a basis
for building up the
repertoire of questions
on which to train the
machine learning model.
So I can see many, many areas
where learning and teachers
and universities and schools
can benefit usually from AI
and machine learning, helping
learners do a lot better.
Imagine they, to me, one of the big ones
is personalized learning where imagine
if every learner could
have a personalized tutor
that could teach them
problems in certain areas
at their own pace
in a way that was completely
customized to them.
To me, that's one of the big holy grails
of teaching and learning.
- No, I couldn't agree more.
These notions of personalization
but I am curious,
how do you think this is going to affect
and I agree with you also
that this will never replace
the teacher, that human
connection actually
was probably going to become even
more important over time as
other things get automated.
But what do you think this is
going to do to labor markets?
Are there going to be,
there's kind of these
techno optimists that say,
"Well, the industrial revolution, yes
a lot of jobs were lost but
a lot of jobs got created."
Do you think that's just
going to be the same thing?
We just have to have some
optimistic faith that will happen
or do we think this time is different
because of the nature of the
tasks that machine learning
and robotics can take on.
And if so, yeah,
how do we get the positives
while mitigating the negatives?
- I think we're seeing some
of this happen today
where jobs get transformed
into new jobs, where just imagine
that let's say for example
you're driving a truck
and autonomous vehicles,
self-driving cars are almost there,
I think there's still some
tweaking that needs to be done
but they're almost there.
And so one could imagine that
you'll think, oh, my goodness
we'll never have people
driving cars anymore.
And for trucks that rumble
from the west coast, the east coast
or wherever in the world,
now you won't have drivers.
But just imagine those would
be, you need other skills.
You need people that maybe
you need a, I don't know
maybe an IT technician or an IT expert
in the truck and making
sure that all the IT
and support systems are working well.
Making sure that there
are fail safe models
and making sure that when you
come to areas where the AI
or machine learning doesn't quite cut it.
I can imagine that if you're trying to,
I've tried to drive a Vespa scooter
on the small streets of
Muradabad near Delhi in India.
And I promise you, I promise you
I don't think that you can have
any machine learning technology
do a self-driving car
or something on the streets of Muradabad
where any random molecule or a particle
or biological entities coming
from every which direction, it's insane.
And so I think you need people for that.
And, but I think we need more
people who are generalists
that can do driving as
well as some other stuff.
So I do see that jobs will
transform into newer jobs
which is why this whole concept
of up-skilling and
re-skilling is so important.
In marketing a lot of the kind
of marketing we did
earlier has now transformed
to digital marketing,
analytics has taken off.
And so today, data science
teams of companies have grown.
They do machine learning,
data science, statistics
and so on and those teams
are becoming bigger.
So even as certain kinds
of teams are diminishing,
you see the burgeoning of IT teams,
you see burgeoning of data science teams.
And I think the same kind
of trend we'll keep up,
will keep happening.
I mean look at the computing
when data centers went away
to the cloud, people said, "Oh my God,
so many jobs will be lost" but guess what?
There's more jobs in computer science,
more jobs in data centers.
We need the ops people.
We need ops support
people that understand how
to do load balancing
and security and privacy
and all of that stuff.
So really jobs get transformed
and you need new kinds
of skills or adjacent skills
that people have to
really become expert on.
- It's interesting, one of
the examples that was given
to me recently which made a
lot of sense was something
like online commerce.
We imagine, I mean, it has
in some ways disrupted a
lot of place-based retail
but it didn't remove, although
maybe machine learning
and robotics might change
some of it but still someone
is picking things,
putting them in a basket.
And actually it has created the new job
of bringing it that last
mile to someone's door
which wasn't there before
because no one had the expectation
that they would be able to
click a few things on an app
and then their groceries
show up at their door
or the book they wanna
buy shows up at the door
within 24 hours.
But it is gonna be interesting.
I hope that we create more jobs
and actually the jobs
are even higher value
but there is this notion of technology
is hyper-productive which means
that you can get the same
output with less labor.
So but my gut sense is
we, edX and Khan Academy,
we got a role to play to make sure
that most of the jobs are gonna be higher
up the value chain, more kind
of knowledge economy jobs.
And so we need to make sure
more people are prepared
to be there in this world we're going to.
(crosstalk)
- I think what's interesting here Sal is
that I actually see this maybe goes back
to quantum mechanics.
I see sort of a cyclical
thing happening here
where as we think we are climbing
up the ladder and learning the
newer and higher tech skills
what we're also seeing
within enterprises is
that more and more employees
and companies are doubling
down on what they call soft skills.
Really, it's better to
call them power skills
or human skills where empathy and teamwork
and collaboration, creativity,
design thinking, empathy.
These are all becoming
a lot more important
where machines don't quite do that.
And so I think we will see
and if we're going back
to the future approach where
or maybe more like future
to the past or whatever
where the human skills will be emphasized
where whether in companies
or in teaching and so on
the human skills will be
emphasized where people can do
what they're good at which is being human.
- I couldn't agree more.
I think there's this
something about technology
and as we get some of
our material needs met
by more and more productive technology,
we realize that some of these
core ideas that we've had
for hundreds of thousands
of years of human history.
The community being part of a
village, being part of a clan,
being part of a tribe, that we've gone
through a first phase of
technology kind of separating us.
And we see it, anxiety,
depression, loneliness
are our really epidemics and
disproportionately epidemic.
It seems in the Western more
materially successful world.
And I hope you're right, that as we,
as more things get automated,
we start realizing, hey
that frees us up to kind of be the humans
in the village and connect
with each other emotionally
and people talk about healthcare.
There's probably gonna be a lot of jobs
it's just make sure
people have companionship,
make sure, there's a lot of
studies that the best doctors
who cares what the
medicine they're giving is,
does the patient feel
like they're being heard
or they feel like they're being cared for?
So and this goes go back
to the quantum physics
and Nisargadatta Maharaj around
perception is often reality.
And this feeling of connectedness.
A feeling is a real thing
that we can't undertake.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Well, this got way more
philosophical than I had expected.
I thought we were just gonna talk
about democratizing education
which is a big idea in of itself.
But you have a lot of folks, young people,
people of all ages, I mean
I'll let you take us home
on where is all this going?
Where do you hope this goes?
What advice, what should
be people's take aways?
- I think it's very simple.
Khan Academy, edX and so on,
have been doing online learning.
You've been doing it
for, oh my God, 15 years.
We've been doing it at
edX for about 10 years.
And we began doing this
well before the pandemic
but then the pandemic hit about a year ago
and the whole world went
to online learning and
online working, remote work.
I think this is here to stay.
I think the one message
I have for everybody is
that the future is gonna be
blended where whether you're
in school or college, there's
gonna be a combination
of online learning and in-person learning.
We will figure it out what are
the best things to do online?
What are the best things to do in person?
So for example, lectures
isn't it better to sit in front of a,
watch short videos and I
call them Khan-style videos,
five, 10 minute videos that you can pause,
rewind as many times as you want.
And you can do it at midnight.
Isn't that so much better than going
to a lecture for 60 minutes
or worst 90 minutes at eight
o'clock in the morning?
And those things are better than online.
However, some other things
like maybe collaborating
with a couple of dorm
mates on a problem set
or building something
or working one-on-one with a professor,
some of these things might
be better than online.
And I think the figured
out the blended model.
So to me, my last message is that
when you're in school, I
would focus on making sure
that you learn how to
learn, not just in person
but also learn how to learn online.
And we actually launched a couple
of courses on edX on how to learn online.
This would be a very critical
skill going in the end
because in the future, all
learning will be a combination
of online and in-person learning.
- I love it, I couldn't agree more.
We always have a good time
chatting Professor Agarwal.
I thank you so much for joining us.
And I'm excited to go
on this journey with you
'cause I think it could make
a big dent in the universe.
- Well, fantastic, Sal.
Always great chatting with you.
You've been an inspiration.
I would not have been doing this
had it not been for the work that you did.
And so just keep up all that you do
and hope we continue to collaborate
and do great things in the future.
- Thank you so much.
- [Anant] Thank you.
Well, thanks everyone for joining.
As you could tell very fun conversation
and myself and Anant go
way, way, way back probably
before he remembers it.
But he was, I don't
remember all my professors
but I definitely remember him.
I had no idea that our lives
would converge in this way
but every few months we get
together when one of us is in,
when he's either in the
Bay area or I'm in Boston.
And we ended up spending hours chatting
about a million different things on
a million different dimension.
So a really, really
interesting guy and edX I think
is doing some incredibly
powerful work and it really picks
up where to some degree
Khan Academy leaves off.
And so I think between
these types of organizations
and others, there's a real chance
to provide really rich resources
for learners and for
educators around the world.
But thank you so much for joining.
Thank you for being (indistinct),
I'm sorry for all of y'all.
I couldn't get to all of your questions.
I will try to be better
about that next time
but thanks for joining us
on this live stream onward.